one of my more notable cosplays is
probably my right cosplayer from league
legends I feel like my misfortune
costume day gender bend of Morgana my
bye was the one that like most people
know before Garin was the my favorite
I've done so many Lee champions and like
for me to pick which one have had the
most fun and like I don't think it would
be possible
some fans play the game for hours
some attend every event some collect
their favourite characters and some fans
become them cosplay isn't just about
dressing up it's a proclamation of your
love for a fandom and an opportunity to
connect and bond with people like you
today we're talking to some of the best
league of legends cosplayers about what
fuels our passion for their craft and
inspires them to push their creativity
to the max characters that like really
inspire me to cosplay them are like
basically badass women dresses with
armor or like hyper armor and then like
some frills like that's like my
aesthetic League of Legends does that
very well and I'm like okay you cosplay
even though the designs are simple at
times they're still bold and dynamic and
colorful and I love that I have a gang
of friends that we always play a rams
together and like Garen is like my man I
saw the cinematic trailer I said like
that let's do it it's gonna be easy
because there's no compound curtains and
that's where I learned to never say
that's gonna be easy because then I
realized he had like three layers of
trim we have like the base plate and
then you have your trim and then the
trim has two pairs of trim on it so it's
like okay so I just made this armor like
four times every time I make a costume
there's that part where you say it's a
curse my hubris there's a lot of
research I put into what I want to do
like alright cool this is not realistic
for this outfit you're gonna have to go
to the bathroom at some point so we're
gonna have to put some zippers in here
I love straight stitching lines like
look how straight I got this little
stitch in the ditch right here and
everybody's I can that's sexy that's a
nice stitch looks real good
every new thing we try to learn a new
technique or to enhance the old ones to
get just a little bit closer to
perfection people on my stream know me
is like the sand Queen because I just 3d
print stuff and then I have to sit there
and stand it forever and ever
practically crying on stream because I
was in so much pain
putting a cosplay on for the first time
when you've worked blood sweat and tears
into it like it's it's incredible with
Geron I'm like an armor I'm like oh I'm
awesome look at me I'm so cool I work so
damn hard
and in Italy I'm like not wearing
anything but the same feelings there I'm
like I'm awesome I got so shredded and I
ate like nothing but chicken and sadness
for three months forget about it it's so
good
like it's the hi I will never get over
it you just you look at yourself and
you're like I did it like I am this
character now when you inhabit the
character a little bit of the character
bleeds in to who you are and at least
for me that manifested itself in a lot
of confidence and I genuinely want
everyone to experience that and to have
that that's sort of like Hollywood star
for a day feeling to kind of carry that
in their lives are like oh you know what
I am worth something I noticed the one
I'm in a costume I'm Way more just
social and stuff like I'm not myself you
get to be somebody else for a day I
cosplay our kids onna at season 2 worlds
and I made an at wall that had
pre-program responses and it was so cool
like having people come up to me talking
and then I would talk to them through my
at wall and they're like wait a second
sona's mute you're being mute a lot of
people or how such deep connections with
their characters and their favorite
champions and when you're able to bring
that to life for them they just get so
overwhelmed and they love it and I love
it when people come up to me and they're
like this is my favorite character can I
please take a million selfies with you
my wicked Lulu ha I had a tutorial
online and apparently like help so many
people out in the community like I'd go
to a random con and people will be like
hey are you Ben Z I used your hat
tutorial thank you so much no matter
what con you go to you could always find
somebody who's also cosplay League so
you're not alone in 2012 Anime Expo I
wanted to keep in touch with all the
other League of Legends cosplayers so I
made the League of Legends called
spirits group at the beginning I would
like invite 20 people to my dorm and we
would have a crafting day convention by
convention year by year more people are
doing it and there's over 18,000 people
as of today and it's just a global
community now of crafters and people
making things my favorite thing of all
times League of Legends cosplay
on reddit we found a thread from this
guy from Canada saying hi
reddit I really want to cosplay can
somebody help me he goes by the area
this is his summoner name and he has
muscular dystrophy and he's an electric
wheelchair he plays actually League
allege ins with his mouth and his feet
and what he wanted to be Corki because
he's like all my life I wanted to cause
by I physically can't and people stare
at me for being in a wheelchair and he's
like so I want people to stare at me for
being a really cool character and Corki
is my main so I reached out to my friend
Brett who is a leader of a cosmic group
called 4hg tasty we raised almost $4,000
to make the costume we filmed the whole
thing where we put him in the costume we
revealed it to him he was super
emotional the people at riot loved it
he likes stole in my opinion world I
like think of cosplay and think I'm like
this is something that's so powerful and
amazing that I was able to be a part of
this is like way bigger than us this is
something that's really special the cool
thing is like all my experience through
cosplay has actually led me to like
building businesses my Ben Z props
business is where I'm making just like
blueprints and like 3d model files for
people make like pet apparel and
accessories there would be a time when I
would stop cosplaying for sure I think I
would still make things either for other
people or hell even my like my kids
maybe my grandkids probably not forever
but for the foreseeable future
until we can't walk anymore until we are
too old to do it there's characters that
I want to do that are you know in their
late 50s and there's like old ladies
that are like in their 80s and I'm like
a freak when I get wrinkles I want to do
that
year-over-year eSports events are
getting bigger and better in the next
episode of this series we're going
behind the scenes at Riot Games LCS
studio to uncover all that goes into
putting on one of the most ambitious
productions in eSports
[Music]
you